[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 10 juin voici
les titres de cette édition
alors que la troisième étape du
déconfinement et enclencher les
entreprises peinent à recruter des
emplois saisonniers sont ni ne serait
pas pour rien que dans le secteur de
l'hôtellerie restauration en france même
si le constat est moins alarmant dans la
région parisienne reportage au parc
france miniature elancourt et puis
invité laurence cousin directrice divine
information jeunesse les élections
régionales et départementales approche
c'est au programme les 20 et 27 juin
prochain deux scrutins organisés avec le
paramètre crise sanitaire
comment les mairies se prépare-t-elle
pour accueillir les électeurs en toute
sécurité exemple à plaisir et coignières
enfin direction magny les hameaux à la
fin de ce journal ou la ferme école
graines d'avenir prépare sa première
rentrée
elle est prévue pour le mois d'octobre
prochain implantée sur le site de bulle
loyer l'établissement forme au métier de
maraîcher primeur une journée portes
ouvertes se tenait ce mercredi se faire
vacciner directement depuis son véhicule
c'est possible cette semaine à
rambouillet la ville a ouvert jusqu'à
demain un maxi drive reportage à suivre
mais j - avant le début de l'euro de
football le match d'ouverture est au
programme ce vendredi à rome entre la
turquie et l'italie
l équipe de france elle fera son entrée
dans la compétition le 15 juin ce sera
face à l'allemagne et les bleus qui ont
reçu aujourd'hui la visite d' emmanuel
macron le président de la république
vous allez peut-être voir les images
s'affichent et ça y est c'est rendu dans
les yvelines à clairefontaine là où se
préparent les hommes de didier deschamps
il était accompagné de la première dame
mme brigitte macron du président de la
fédération française de football noël le
graet mais aussi du président de la fifa
à djénine fantino l équipe de france
figure dans le groupe f du tournoi qui
fait office de poule de la mort en
compagnie de l'allemagne donc mais aussi
du portugal champion d'europe en titre
et de la hongrie un tournoi qui est
itinérant cette année dans 11 villes
européennes auxquelles vont donc se
prêter les 24 sélections qualifiées pour
l'euro 2020 l'actualité c'est aussi la
france qui est entré depuis hier dans
l'allée dans l'étape 3 du déconfinement
le couvre-feu est passé à 23 heures et
les restaurants peuvent à nouveau
accueillir des clients en intérieur un
nouveau souffle pour ceux qui ont
largement souffert de la crise et les
clients sont au rendez vous pour
soutenir leurs établissements habituel
reportage dans une pizzeria de
versailles avec astrid bergès des
clients souriant et nombreux à la
pizzeria césar bas et simonetta noni la
terrasse n'a pas désempli dans la soirée
du mercredi 9 juin
cette journée marquait une nouvelle
étape dans le déconfinement il est
désormais possible de manger en
intérieur et surtout le couvre-feu était
repoussé à 23 heures ça changeait tout
parce que c'est pas que ça nous permet
de faire des services et par l'essentiel
c'est surtout que les clients puissent
avoir le temps de manger tranquillement
qui chante pas pressé de partir les gens
qui arrivent à l'intérêt envers dizaine
ont parfois 20h45 pour les aviser
écouter les vestiaires on voulait mais
emporté on peut pas ou servir c'était
vraiment assez désagréable c'était un
petit ver sert en fait le restaurant est
idéalement situé à proximité du château
de versailles
si les touristes internationaux ne sont
pas encore revenus les français de tout
l'hexagone
eux sont bien présents a décidé d'aller
à versailles pour visiter le château de
versailles
donc combat visited main mais on a dit
on avenue a joué auparavant pour
profiter de l'ouverture des restaurants
pour justement parce que c'est ce qu'on
attendait plus longtemps pour profiter
un peu des terrasses et puis si le temps
ne nous permet alors ça c'est impeccable
parce qu'à strasbourg y pleut
actuellement à donc on a fait le bon
choix je pense et ses clients n'étaient
pas retourner au restaurant depuis des
mois c'est couvre-feu à 23h les a
motivés ça l'est déjà au niveau des
restaurants parce qu'on peut mieux
choisir les restaurants les terrasses et
puis bon effectivement d'avoir le temps
c'est quand même très appréciable même
si des clients pouvaient aller en
intérieur peut on fait ce choix en
raison du temps prochaine étape du
déconfinement le 30 juin
les restaurants pour ouvrir à 100% leur
jauge en intérieur et couvre feu sera
supprimé la saison estivale commence
donc à peine mais les professionnels
peinent à employer ouverture incertaine
et tardive emploi avec plus de confort
et les raisons des saisonniers se
détournant de ces professions sont
multiples à france nature le parc de
loisirs d'elancourt quelques postes sont
encore vacants une situation provoquée
par la crise sanitaire
mélanie poké et bérangère bourgoin
nettoyage des infections il n'est pas
encore deezer france miniature s'éveille
avant d'accueillir ses premiers
visiteurs
marly diakota y est hôtesse d'accueil
polyvalente c'est sa quatrième saison
sur le site élan courtois avec le co
vite ça un peu compliqué c'était pas
évident mais quand je suis une ancienne
ils ont préféré aussi me reprendre et
parce que j'avais beaucoup plus
d'expérience dans l'entreprise en lui
même
j'ai eu d'autres propositions ailleurs
mais on m'a proposé ici et du coupage et
préfère revenir ici france miniature
emplois à l'année 17 permanent étudiants
habitués les saisonniers sont eux près
d'une quarantaine
il ya différents métiers parce que rp un
établissement recevant du public comme
le nôtre regroupe différents commerces
métiers des restaurants boutiques
donc c'est pour couvrir tous ses aspects
donc à la fois la partie muséale du parc
mais également les attractions puisqu'on
a également des attractions pour les
enfants et familles la direction a connu
un recrutement plus compliqué cette
saison fabrice la loure a vu certains
employés accepter d'autres postes dans
des secteurs où l'activité a repris
plutôt la difficulté de recrutement
cette année a été et est surtout liée à
l'incertitude de notre pas les nôtres
recrutement était total et complet au
mois de mars dernier avec une prévision
d'ouvertures pour le début avril
et c'est vrai que le fait de faire
attendre nos saisonniers ne sachant pas
notre couverture on a une déperdition
bien légitime
ils sont allés trouver d'autres métiers
ailleurs trois postes sont encore à
pourvoir à l'accueil aux attractions et
dans le management france miniature est
ouvert jusqu'au vacances de la toussaint
et pour parler de ce sujet et laurence
cousin est avec nous par visioconférence
bonsoir bonsoir la directrice divine
information jeunesse c'est le centre
départemental d'information jeunesse
yvelinois y/y j propose un accueil
personnalisé gratuit des espaces
thématiques en libre consultation est
aussi est des services d aide pour les
jeunes le constat qui est fait au niveau
national on parle d'une pénurie
c'est le mot pénurie qui est avancé
notamment dans le secteur de
l'hôtellerie-restauration cent mille
postes ne serait pas pourvus pour ses
offres d'emploi saisonnière est ce que
ce constat vous le faites au niveau
yvelinois ou est ce que le terme pénurie
vous semble quelque peu exagéré le
constat oui je pense qu'il est il est
même pour pour tout le moins en fait
c'est le contact sanitaire effectivement
le manque de visibilité dans un premier
temps des entreprises qui ne savait pas
si elle pouvait recruter si les
structures allait ouvrir dans des
conditions optimales
et puis les professionnels notamment du
secteur de l'hôtellerie restauration qui
n'ayant pas eu de travail pendant
quelque temps se sont reconvertis pour
certains et ont retrouvé un autre
travailleur donc de fait effectivement
il ya peut-être aussi un potentiel pour
les jobs d'été pour les saisonniers les
jeunes qui n'ont pas ou peu de
qualifications de se positionner à
maintenant à cette façon là on va en
parler dans un instant d'ailleurs on
parle d'emploi saisonnier de jobs d'été
est ce qu'il ya une différence entre les
deux finalement c'est peu ou prou la
même chose
on parle bien effectivement d'emplois
saisonniers
l'emploi saisonnier plus générique c'est
à dire qu'il peut aussi concerner la
saison d'hiver pour ceux qui par exemple
peuvent faire de l'animation ou de la
restauration mais plutôt là du coup sur
les stations de ski cet hiver
vous parliez du secteur de l'hôtellerie
restauration qui est particulièrement
concernée ce qu'il y en a d'autres où
finalement c'est vraiment le principal
secteur concerné ça reste les poulets
pour les jobs d'été pour les jeunes a
effectivement ce sont les mêmes secteurs
d'activités qui sont concernés donc bien
sûr une hôtellerie restauration
l'animation à le service services à la
personne entretien nettoyage et
différents secteurs où les jeunes
peuvent se positionne positionner sur un
emploi saisonnier
alors vous parliez tout à l'heure de des
explications finalement face à ces
difficultés de recrutement c'est ça
c'est des saisonniers peut-être qu'ils
ont profité de la crise sanitaire pour
se reconvertir dans l'autre côté il ya
des jeunes alors qu'ils ont soit pas
forcément le permis qui ne sont pas
forcément qualifié peut-être pour pour
ces emplois saisonniers
c'est toutes ces raisons complètement
alors c'est ça aussi c'est pour ça qu'on
le réseau information jeunesse est là
aussi pour accompagner en amont les
jeunes qui souhaitent trouver un job
d'été
il faut qu'ils se posent les bonnes
questions c'est combien de temps je suis
disponible
est-ce que je suis mobile et puis c'est
quoi mon premier intérêt à travailler
est ce que c'est pour gagner de l'argent
financer mes études par exemple ou bien
c'est pour enrichir mon cv donc je veux
faire aussi je vais avoir une mission
qui m'intéresse et sportives
donc ça c'est des choses que sur
lesquels on peut que s'accompagner assez
beaucoup de bon sens finalement mais
aussi on peut les accompagner sur tout
ce qui est rédaction du cv la lettre de
motivation
et puis aussi les aiguiller sur les
centres ressources aller il ya beaucoup
de choses maintenant qui se passe sur
sur le web donc des sites spécialisés où
ils pourront trouver des offres adaptées
à leurs à leurs recherches pour
retrouver il ya le site internet directv
78 qui va s'afficher saillie s'affiche
en bas de l'écran
ce problème
dont on ne parle ce soir est ce qu'il
est il est forcément nouveau ou c'est un
problème qu'on a vu aussi émergé dans
les années précédentes finales on peut
être exacerbée cette année avec la crise
sanitaire
cette difficulté de recrutement des
emplois saisonniers c'est quelque chose
de nouveau ou pas finalement
bah c'est surtout en terme de temps
pourra éviter que ça change parce que
comme ça a été dit sur le précédent
reportage en fait en général les jobs
d'été on s'en préoccupe en début d'année
nous par exemple nos forums de dt la
rencontre entre les recruteurs et les
jeunes ça se fait en mars avril et l'a
finalement on a l'impression qu'on
attendait on attendait on attendait et
là tout d'un coup ça c'est maintenant a
donc ces voix là c'est pour ceux qui
sont réactifs et là qui cherchent un
emploi
mais en fait la balle est dans leur camp
donc ça c'est à lui de se positionner
maintenant mais c'est vrai que c'est ces
retards par rapport aux années
précédentes bien sûr il ya beaucoup
d'offres en ce moment oui il ya des
offres
bon bah on connaît les centres
ressources à même sur un achat d'une
solution il ya des offres de jobs d'été
en quantité qui sont qui sont proposés
après ce sens de l'orientation pour
l'alternance pour tout autre sujet
l'idée faut que ça match en fait il faut
que ça marche entre l'entreprise
l'offre qui est proposé est la personne
qu en face donc c'est ça que je souhaite
à toutes les entreprises notamment
yvelinoise et le type d'offre dans quel
secteur vous en parlait il ya un sens et
ceux de l'hôtellerie restauration de
l'animation il ya plusieurs siècles vous
propose aussi des sessions bafa parce
que effectivement il ya aussi une
problématique notamment pour les jeunes
mineurs on n'en parle pas souvent mais
eux aussi ils ont envie de s'investir et
d'avoir leur premier job pour certains
bah là pour le coup c'est vrai que la
crise allait desservir très largement
mais c'est possible quand même
légalement qu'ils puissent travailler à
partir de 16 ans a donc nous leur donner
d'information les conseille et puis pour
ceux qui veulent faire de l'animation
wallon propose des formations passa donc
un brevet qui leur permet de se préparer
aux techniques d'animation auprès des
jeunes une dernière question qui
concerne plus civil information jeunesse
comment vous êtes vous adapté en ces
temps de crise sanitaire forcément avec
des événements qui ont pas pu forcément
se tenir vous parliez tout à l'heure du
forum jobs d'été qui est un peu un
classique
al'approche de l'été comment accompagner
les jeunes les informer avec ce
paramètre crise sanitaire comment vous
êtes vous adapté et bien effectivement
avec pas forcément beaucoup de moyens
mais comme pour beaucoup on sait on a on
a la chance on a la force d'un réseau un
réseau national monsieur régionale et
donc à job d'été au niveau du cdj adq
point com qui permet de recenser toutes
les offres de jobs d'été donc vous
pouvez encore bien sûr vous connecter
pour avoir les offres mais il ya eu
aussi des tutos méthodologique pour le
premier contrat de travail pour
décrypter un petit peu les techniques de
recherche d'emploi aussi et puis voilà
il ya eu aussi des des visio avec des
professionnels ils ont pu rencontrer des
professionnels mais de manière
dématérialisée et on vous retrouve une
nouvelle fois sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
laurence cousin d'avoir été avec nous
ses roues directrices divine information
jeunesse
[Musique]
depuis lundi la ville de rambouillet a
ouvert son maxi drive éphémère à
l'hippodrome la vaccination en drive est
accessible jusqu'à demain soir vendredi
ici tout se fait dans la voiture la
tente les déplacements et même parfois
le vaccin elle mercredi soir 1500
premières doses avait déjà pu être
injectées justin brasier une vague si
drive éphémère à rambouillet la première
opération de vaccination en drive dans
les yvelines
ici les personnes peuvent recevoir une
première dose du vaccin files heures
presque sans descendre de leur voiture
un système qui permet d'être plus rapide
sur place l'équipe est en capacité de
vacciner 1200 personnes par jour c'est
vraiment pour fluidifier permettent un
maximum de vaccination en un minimum de
temps et finalement potentialiser le
temps les personnes venant se faire
vacciner parce que ça évite tout
simplement le moment de trouver un
stationnement pour pouvoir aller dans un
centre de vaccination
concrètement un sens de circulation a
été mis en place
première étape un questionnaire à
remplir avant d'arriver à la zone de
vaccination la deuxième étape est donc
la vaccination par un professionnel de
santé ou un pompier après avoir revu le
questionnaire avec la personne est bien
être certain qu'il n'ya aucune
problématique
il n'y a pas de problématique la
personne est vacciné et termine sur la
troisième zone qui est la zone
administrative un certificat de
vaccination est ensuite fourni avec un
rendez-vous de deuxième dose il peut
être effectué sur ce même centre ou
ailleurs depuis le début de la semaine
entre 1500 et 2000 premières doses ont
déjà été injectés
c'est pratique c'est rapide en plus la
part de problèmes de stationnement
donc voila c'était l'occasion en fait ça
a été très rapide et ça je pense que
quand les gens travaillent c'est une
bonne chose de pouvoir se faire vacciner
assez rapidement et et puis bal en plus
rester à proximité notre voiture s'est
quand même
en plus on n'attend pas pendant des
heures donc donc en tout cas c'est pau
c'est positif
là je suis encore n'avait travaillé
parce que je viens de sortir du logis du
boulot et j'ai fait ça dans cinq minutes
donc c'est ça a été rapide la vaccine
drive de rambouillet est encore
accessible jusqu'à demain vendredi 11
juin 20h30 avec ou sans rendez vous dans
six semaines de l'opération sera
réitérée pour les deuxième dose dans
l'actualité politique l'élection
municipale de 2020 a définitivement
validé à conflans sainte honorine
le conseil d'état a rejeté le recours
déposé par l'opposition suite au scrutin
où l'abstention a été pointé du doigt
cette décision vient confirmer celle du
tribunal administratif de versailles qui
avait statué en décembre
laurent bros élu depuis 2014 conserve
donc son fauteuil de maire il s'est dit
ravi sur son compte twitter de pouvoir
continuer à accompagner les conflanais
fin juin deux autres scrutins à sont au
programme les départementales et
régionales rendez vous les 20 et 27 juin
entre la crise sanitaire et cette double
échéance électorale les municipalités
sont sur le pied de guerre pour tout
organiser
reportage à plaisir et coignières
d'eléonore sinoquet agrafeuse stylo
scotch
le cahier des modifications la liste
d'émargement la liste des consultations
enfin tout le matériel qui va nous
servir à plaisir depuis deux semaines 42
bureaux de vote sont actuellement
installés afin d'accueillir les quelques
19500 électeurs inscrits les 20 et 27
juin prochains tout le personnel
communal est mobilisé d'autant que cette
année il faut également composer avec
les nouvelles mesures sanitaires
on rentre par une porte d'entrée on
ressort par la sortie sans jamais se
croiser
nous avons prévu des masques
éventuellement pour les électeurs qui
pourraient pourrait arriver sans masque
des mesures sanitaires qui rendent le
recrutement des assesseurs plus
compliqué cent soixante personnes sont
nécessaires au bon déroulement des
scrutins
on essaie d'avoir plein d'assesseurs
c'est vraiment vraiment difficile je
pense qu'on va tenir le tenir le sujet
c'est très compliqué c'est des journées
au téléphone pour essayer de de motiver
les gens
deux ans pour éviter les flux sortants
et entrants
du côté de la plus petite commune de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines avec 2500 un électeur
coignières la charge de travail aussi
est importante pour ces élections
on a besoin quand même de beaucoup de
choses on a besoin dizaine de tables et
une trentaine de chaises on a besoin de
deux urnes
la commune de coignières c'est ces deux
bureaux de vote 1 c'est pas 18 bureaux
mais malgré tout sa nécessité quand même
un travail je dirais très précis
coignard a aussi mis en place les
mesures sanitaires nécessaires contre le
coc vide et pour simplifier les choses
la municipalité a choisi de délocaliser
ses bureaux de vote initialement situé à
la mairie et à l'école bové ils seront
regroupés au gymnase du moulin à vent
ils sont sur le même lieu mais ils
seront distincts pour les électeurs avec
une entrée et une sortie distingue pour
les deux bureaux algie menacé quand même
un espace de plus de 1000 mètres carrés
ça nous donne la possibilité de
regrouper deux bureaux avec nos deux
scrutins dans chaque bureau
donc voilà c'est plus simple aussi d'un
point de vue logistique côté assesseurs
le maire la sueur pas de souci
particulier
tous les élus et agents de la commune
seront mobilisés reste à savoir aussi
bien à coignières cas plaisir
si les électeurs eux seront au
rendez-vous à voter direction magny les
hameaux pour la fin de ce journal ou la
toute nouvelle ferme école graines
d'avenir organisé une journée portes
ouvertes c'était ce mercredi
en octobre elle accueillera sa première
promotion d'étudiants présentant
présentation avec eléonore sinoquet et
justine braz et 8 hectares pour
apprendre le métier de maraîcher primer
c'est l'objectif de la ferme école
graines d'avenir de magny les hameaux
elle organisé des portes ouvertes
mercredi 9 juin pour recruter ses futurs
étudiants mais également pour présenter
le concept de l'établissement la ferme
école de graines d'avenir associé agro
écologie et enseignement innovants pour
former des jeunes dès 15 ans au métier
de maraîcher primer les jeunes vont être
mises en situation de vivre le métier de
maraîcher primeur et vont passer deux
tiers de leur temps à faire de la
pratique ils vont satisfaire à de vraies
commandes vrais clients au prix du
marché et pendant un tiers du temps
restant ils vont apprendre des
enseignements théoriques installée sur
le site historique de bulles loyer et
appartenant à l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
le site était inoccupée puis en
réhabilitation depuis 2016
depuis mars on est en train de remettre
en exploitation la ferme
l'objectif est d'avoir une exploitation
en fonctionnement en septembre octobre
autre objectif de graines d'avenir être
un écosystème entre les territoires les
jeunes et les entreprises pour les
territoires on va lutter contre le
décrochage scolaire on va lutter contre
le chômage des jeunes pour les
entreprises on va mettre sur le marché
des jeunes qui sont formés et rapidement
opérationnelles spécifiquement aux
métiers et enfin pour les jeux on va
leur proposer une troisième voie
complémentaire entre le lycée
professionnel et le
cfa la ferme école accueillera donc
douze jeunes par promotion pour une
formation de trois ans à l'issue de
celle ci deux diplômes leur seront
délivrés ans et ap primeur ainsi qu'un
titre professionnel d'ouvriers de
production horticole pour découvrir une
autre journée portes ouvertes est
organisée le 23 juin prochain
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]